let's talk briefly about former Democrat
and former Democratic presidential
candidate and former democratic
congresswoman Tulsi gabbard the other
day on Twitter I asked the question what
is tulsi's next pivot now that almost
everyone or is it everyone she endorsed
lost or may lose we found out what the
next pivot is going to be and I'm going
to tell you in a moment but before we do
that if you want to find someone with an
even worse endorsement record than Trump
you have to look at tool C look at this
the new Republic with a nice write-up
about this nearly every Republican Tulsi
gabbard endorse lost the election these
are the numbers Tulsi gabbard endorsed
13 Republican candidates and 10 of them
lost and she endorsed some real
extremists for someone who has made the
claim that it is the Democratic party
that lost her
that she is leaving the Democratic party
because she is the moderate she is the
critical thinker she is the for lack of
a better term enlightened Centrist and
then all of a sudden she's endorsing
Herschel Walker she's endorsing Carrie
Lake John Gibbs that's not critical
thinking and it's certainly not
moderation those are some of the most
extreme candidates out there the new
Republic summarized this she in the
house endorsed John Gibbs who I
interviewed he's out of his mind uh and
he lost Tom Barrett and Joe Kent all of
them lost
on the Senate side she endorsed Blake
Masters who thankfully lost one of the
worst and most dangerous candidates this
cycle Adam laxalt in Nevada thankfully
he lost and done Baldock in New
Hampshire good thing he lost as well and
then as far as Governors go Tulsi
endorsed Kerry Lake we learned yesterday
that yes indeed she lost Darren Bailey
in Illinois lost Tudor Dixon in Michigan
she lost and Lee zeldin in New York the
three people she endorsed to one were JD
Vance for Ohio Senator he was already
well ahead at the point at which she
endorsed him Mike Lee for Utah senator
okay that's maybe the most contested one
here even though he was doing very well
in the polls and then Christie known for
South Dakota governor she's very popular
in South Dakota meaningless endorsement
she was obviously going to win so a
disastrous endorsement record for Tulsi
so then we get to what is her next step
what's her next pivot some of you wrote
to me and said tulsi's next pivot is
going to be becoming
overtly transphobic because that's
what's doing really well right now among
the Republican Party well maybe but the
actual news is that Tulsi gabbard has
joined Fox News we used to joke about
this months and months and months ago
when a year maybe longer when we started
to see the tool C transformation
we all were joking she is really lined
up to be a Fox News contributor and it
was
a joke but one of those jokes where you
say Well it actually could become a
reality she is now a Fox News
contributor the hill reporting Tulsi
gabbard inc's contributor deal with Fox
News
a spokesperson for Fox confirmed
gabbard's hiring on Tuesday
she has emerged as a leading critic of
liberals
and it has been campaigning with a
number of trump-backed Republicans
during the recent cycle she regularly
has appeared on Fox over several months
she has guest hosted Tucker Carlson
tonight she was on a fox's afternoon
table talk program the five and occupied
the seat typically reserved for
Democrats and liberals so is this the
end of I mean listen we're dealing with
a right winger now Tulsi gabbard is the
absolutely typical reactionary
populist-esque
I don't even know if the word
libertarian applies she was very clearly
a Democrat because being a Democrat was
how she was going to be elected to the
house representing her home state of
Hawaii
and there was really nothing special
about being a Democrat some of the
people who fond over her from the left
were saying well she's against regime
change Wars who isn't who isn't and oh I
Hillary was going to get us into three
Wars was she Biden's gonna get us into
three Wars well he hasn't so far and
he's halfway through his first term
once that fell out of favor or was no
longer useful she started the pivot well
we need to defend speech and there's a
little too much wokeness and suppression
of speech on the left and I can see it
clearly because I'm inside it was all Bs
and she has now gone full circle she
endorsed the most extremist lunatics
running in 2022 just about every single
one of them lost thankfully and now
she's a Fox News contributor what does
she have to look forward to well maybe
this check this out